aquí tenemos esta serie infinita y vamos
a ver se parece a una serie geométrica
porque cuando pasamos del primer término
al segundo estamos multiplicando por
menos 3 y después para pasar al
siguiente terminó nuevamente
multiplicamos por menos 3 así que
tenemos una razón común igual a menos 3
y podemos reescribir esta serie como
menos 0.5 por menos 3 a la cero menos
0.5 por menos 3 elevado a la primera
potencia menos 0.5 por menos 3 al
cuadrado y así sucesivamente entonces
siempre es 0.5 por menos 3 elevado a las
diferentes potencias pero también
podemos escribir esto en notación sigma
miren esto es igual a la suma que va
desde n igual a cero hasta infinito es
decir que esto continúa y continua
la suma de lo primero que tenemos aquí
que se multiplica por menos 3 elevado a
alguna potencia entonces tenemos menos
0.5 por menos 3 elevado a la potencia n
y aquí n es igual a 0 después es igual a
1 y aquí
n es igual a 2 entonces hemos podido
escribir esto de diferentes formas pero
veamos si podemos evaluarlo tenemos una
razón común de menos tres
aquí nuestra r es igual a menos 3 y lo
primero en lo que tenemos que pensar es
que para que esto pueda converger la
magnitud de nuestra razón común o el
valor absoluto de la razón común tiene
que ser menor a 1 para que exista
convergencia pero cuál es el valor
absoluto de menos 3 bueno el valor
absoluto de -3 es 3
así que definitivamente no es menor a 1
entonces esto no converge
no converge
e incluso si analizamos esto tiene
sentido porque la magnitud de cada uno
de estos términos se va haciendo más y
más grande y vamos cambiando entre sumar
y restar pero cada vez estamos sumando y
restando valores más y más y más grandes
y cuando las cosas convergen cada
término exitoso tiende a hacerse muy
pequeño o incluso hasta puede que se
cancele de alguna forma pero como en
este caso el valor absoluto de la razón
común es mayor a 1 esto no converge